so I'm sitting here going through my 452
email now finally I kind of on vacation
with Lizzy's parents of Naples after
Miami business trip and Anthony from
Newport blinds emails me saying I work
at my family's window covering
manufacturing business in sales and
service to our dealers i watch a lot of
your videos and get very motivated by
them I'm ready to work my face off which
is a good thing
can I still put use the principles that
you speak about in your speeches and
still get people excited about window
covering I very much appreciate respect
your thoughts and here they are Anthony
guys here's what it comes down to it in
my opinion and it's only one man's
opinions is that it comes down to
storytelling I think storytelling is the
game you've got to tell your story so
there's an enormous amount of content in
window covering I don't care about them
but millions of people probably do so
you take a little flip like this and you
go around and you talk about window you
know coverings and you do things and you
don't worry about the lighting or your
mic you worry about the content and
pumping out your story you know
articulating what you're about what your
company's about the product is about
that's the game the story you tell is
the whole game and then once you're done
telling the story get into the trenches
so telling your story that's the game
anybody can do it
whether you're dentist whether you cut
trees whether you're fish for mackerel I
don't care what you do tell your story
people listen and then respect their
thoughts